Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui
dans ScienceClic, le vide.
Dans le langage courant,
le vide désigne l'absencede toute matière visible.
On dit par exemple qu'un verre est vide,
à partir du moment où ilne contient pas de liquide.
En réalité, d'un point de vue fondamental,
le verre n'est pasréellement vide.
Bien au contraire, il renferme
un nombre gigantesque de molécules d'air,
plusieursmilliers de milliards de milliards,
qui forment un gaz invisible à l’œil nu,
mais qui constituent uneforme
de matière bel et bien réelle, et concrète.
Dans l'optique de réaliser
certains typesd'expériences,
il peut être intéressant de s'affranchir
de l'air ambiant, dont la présencepourrait être dérangeante.
Pour ce faire, il suffit en quelque sorte de
pomper l'air, pourle faire sortir d'un récipient.
Dans la pratique, il est impossible de créer un vide parfait,
maison peut aujourd'hui s'en approcher
fortement, grâce à des techniques modernes
quipermettent de réduire de plusieurs milliers de milliards de fois,
le nombrede particules présentes dans le récipient.
Cela dit, les vides de laboratoire les plusextrêmes
sont quand même loin d'être parfaitement vides,
Ils fourmillent encore de plusieurs
milliards de particules dans chaque mètre cube.
Si l'on veut trouver un milieu qui soitencore
plus vide que ceux qu'on crée en laboratoire,
il est nécessaire de quitter
l'atmosphèreterrestre, pour voyager dans l'espace.
Dans l'espace entre les planètes tout d'abord,  par exemple au seinde notre système solaire, les particules sont très rares.
On en compte seulement quelques
dizainesde millions par mètre cube.
Mais c'est dans le milieu
intergalactique, c'est-à-dire entre lesgalaxies,
que l'on trouve le vide le plus parfait,
avec en moyenne une seule particule parmètre cube.
Avec une densité si faible, il faudrait s'intéresser
à un volumecapable d'englober notre planète entière,
si l'on voulait retrouver le même nombre
de particules que dans un verre vide.
Dans le vide, en l'absence de matière,
certaines propriétés qui noussont familières cessent d'exister.
Tout d'abord, si l'on essayait de
jouer de la guitare dans le vide,
il serait impossible d'entendre quoi que ce
soit, car la vibration des cordes ne pourrait
pas se propager jusqu'à nos oreilles.
Plusgénéralement, en l'absence de toute forme
de matière pour pouvoir communiquer les vibrations,
le son ne peut pas se propager dans le vide.
Ensuite, à la surface de la Terre, l'atmosphère
exerce un poids, avec lequel elle va appuyer sur les objets
qu'elle contient. Elle exerce
ainsiune force d'écrasement colossale.
Cette force équivaut au poids
de deux éléphants adultes pourchaque mètre carré de surface.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la pression atmosphérique.
Si on ne la ressent pasau quotidien,
c'est parce que notre corps et laplupart des objets
génèrent également une
pression interne, vers l'extérieur, qui s'yoppose parfaitement.
Cependant, imaginons que
l'on s'intéresse par exemple à une bouteille en
plastique, dans laquelle on va faire le vide, en
pompant l'air qu'elle contient.
Maintenant qu'elle est vide, la bouteille ne peut plus s'opposer
à la pression extérieure,
car elle ne contient plus rien.
Elle va donc se faire comprimer
brutalement, par le poids de l'atmosphère.
Enfin, un espace vide
n'a pas de températureà proprement parler.
En effet, on appelle température le degré
d'agitation des particulesau sein d'un milieu.
Dans l'air par exemple, il fait plus chaud
lorsque les molécules d'airsont plus agitées,
et plus froid lorsqu'elles sont plus calmes.
Dans le vide, en l'absencede particules,
il est impossible de mesurer le
degré d'agitation de quoi que ce soit,
et lanotion de température,
au sens d'agitation, n'a donc plus aucune valeur.
Le transport de chaleurne peut plus se faire
qu'à travers la lumière et les autres ondes électromagnétiques,
qui sont le seultype d'ondes, avec les
ondes gravitationnelles, capables de se propager dans le vide.
Imaginons désormais que l'on puisse
s'intéresser au vide, non plus à notre échelle,
mais à des échelles microscopiques.
Toute lamatière qui nous compose est faite d'atomes.
Un atome consiste en un noyau,
autour duquelorbitent des électrons.
Le noyau est près de 100 000 fois
plus petit que l'atome dansson ensemble,
mais il monopolise à lui tout seul 99,9 % de sa masse totale.
Le volumed'un atome
est donc principalement vide, ce qui signifie,
en quelque sorte, quetoute
la matière visible est composée en majorité de vide
Pour conclure, même l'espace le plus vide
possible, ne sera en réalité jamais parfaitementvide.
En effet, selon la physique quantique le
vide est constamment rempli d'une multitude
de particules virtuelles, qui
apparaissentet disparaissent en permanence.
C'est ce qu'on appelle les fluctuations du vide.
Uneparticule virtuelle, est une particule
qui existe pendant une durée tellement courte,
qu'il nous est absolument impossible de l'observer.
Les lois de la physiquequantique
autorisent des particules de ce type à apparaître à partir de rien,
à conditionqu'elles disparaissent
suffisamment vite, afin qu'il soit impossible de les observer.
Les particules virtuelles ne pouvant pas être observées,
elles ont le droit de posséder despropriétés
étranges, qui défient les lois de la physique classique,
comme par exemple le
fait qu'elles apparaissent à partir du vide,
ou encore le fait que certaines
puissent posséder une énergie négative.
Bien qu'elles soient impossibles à observer,
l'existence de ces particules virtuelles entraîne
cependant des phénomènes concrets et mesurables.
D'une part, elles sont à la base
des quatre interactions fondamentales de l'univers.
C'est parexemple en s'échangeant des photons virtuels,
que deux charges électriques
sont capables d'interagir à distance.
D'autre part, elles ont également des effets indirects,
comme le fait qu'ellesgénèrent
une certaine pression sur les objets,
Ou encorele fait que les trous
noirs puissent s'évaporer au cours du temps,
leur attraction gravitationnelletrès forte
permettant de transformer
les particules virtuelles en particules ordinaires,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le rayonnement de Hawking.
Beaucoup de scientifiques pensent
que l'énergiequantique contenue par le vide,
pourrait être une explication à la nature de
l'énergie sombre, cette fameuse forme d'énergie inconnue
qui tend à expandre l'univers de plus enplus vite.
Mais lorsque l'on compare son
intensité avec celle de l'énergiesombre,
on trouve une valeur cent milliards de
septendécillions de fois tropgrande.
C'est l'un des plus grands
mystères non résolus de la science moderne,
On l'a baptisé la catastrophe du vide.